[Música]
en argentina existe desde el 2012 una
ley de identidad de género que busca
promover el respeto de los derechos de
todos los ciudadanos y habitantes del
país sea cual sea su autopercepción de
género pero falta un paso reglamentario
para que esa ley se viera reflejada en
los documentos oficiales eso cambio el
21 de julio del 2021 cuando el gobierno
emitió un decreto reglamentario y
argentina se convirtió en el primer país
de américa latina en permitir el uso de
la equis como alternativa a femenino o
masculino en el dni el documento de
identificación es esencial para todo
tipo de trámites y para el
reconocimiento de las personas ante el
estado de las empresas ese es nuestro
tema en ellas hoy
la opción no binaria era un reclamo
histórico de los sectores lgtb
en el país y representa un importante
cambio para muchas personas sin embargo
la implementación no ha sido sencilla y
muchos se enfrentan demoras para lograr
modificar su documento natalio coso en
nuestro corresponsal en argentina
acompañó a una persona en el proceso
para cambiar su dni en tono diamante
silva quien trabaja en un centro
comunitario de la comunidad lgtb
está entre las primeras personas de
argentina en obtener un documento
nacional de identidad un dni no binario
primeramente obviamente una felicidad
enorme gigante
obviamente lo comparte con toda la mi
gente que estuvo acompañada con con el
proceso
sobre todo con sus compañeras trans como
eliana espinoza sentía en la figura de
nosotras una guía una guía un espejo
fue pionera en esto prácticamente
en julio de 2021 el gobierno emitió un
decreto que habilitaba el uso de la
equis y apenas un mes después cuando
decidió avanzar con su trámite no me
siento muy representada por esta de
mitos prefiero a tener la x mil veces si
no la m y mi nombre es y eso tampoco lo
hago
si tenía turnos pasar
vas a usar este nombre por un inglés
acabas a poner en
el
directorio
[Música]
gracias por la atención pero las cosas
no iban a ser tan simples la fluidez de
las políticas públicas que pregona la
letra de la ley y suele chocar con el
dique de la burocracia estatal
algo que conoce bien el abogado
alejandro mamani quien asesora a
personas del colectivo lgtb
muchas veces en muchas provincias
demoran más de seis meses un año para la
rectificación de la partida de
nacimiento que posteriormente necesaria
para la tramitación del dni cuando
diamante
en el caso de juan o desde que inició el
trámite de modificación de la partida de
nacimiento hasta que le entregaron el
nuevo dni pasaron más de cuatro meses y
aquí en el centro comunitario hay
quienes han vivido situaciones más
difíciles con el trámite como joseph
juárez cuando me llevó la partida llegó
usted tardó más o menos tres meses y
cuando me gestionaron el dni me lo
gestionaron mal me volvieron a mandar el
mismo
yo sé cómo el resto quiere conocer la
experiencia de juana y cómo sigue su
proceso
aunque la actualización de sus datos en
las bases públicas y privadas avanza muy
lentamente ya dio el paso más importante
y ahora puede ayudar al resto a
transitar el mismo camino
para conversar sobre este tema está en
ella soy carolina von opiela abogada de
experta en temas de identidades de
género además carolina estuvo entre las
personas que idearon esa fórmula para
incluir el género no binario en el dni y
es activista una bienvenida para usted y
lo primero porque la dificultad para
poner esa equis en los documentos de
quienes desean hacer el cambio que tal
encantada muchas gracias por la
invitación la dificultad está dada por
distintos sistemas dentro de los actores
involucrados en sistema y de identidad
identificación y de las prácticas
tradicionalmente incluidas y de las
normativas internacionales establecidas
por suerte se ha logrado un corrimiento
a este obstáculo y se ha garantizado una
mejor práctica precisamente con el
dictado de este decreto el 476 está el
año pasado pero surgen todavía
inconvenientes para identificar con
mayor diversidad las categorías de
expresiones de géneros de todas las
personas en la argentina y en la región
y las mayores dificultades en el sistema
argentino eran que la argentina tiene un
documento nacional de identidad y a su
vez funciona como pasaporte en el ámbito
del mercosur por lo cual tenía que
atender las necesidades y los requisitos
de los estándares de seguridad
internacional para los documentos de
viajes y precisamente la argentina había
adherido a una de las convenciones
internacionales que estaban dadas por la
organización de la aviación civil
internacional
la denominaba así que pertenece al
sistema de naciones unidas que había en
argentina debido a un convenio de
chicago que la mayoría de los países
tienen esta adhesión y que establecía
requisitos y entre los requisitos estaba
la consignación sí o sí expresa del
componente sexo como pregunta de un
casillero y una respuesta que la
respuesta sea femenina masculina o de
categoría
x1 que significa que es en el caso no es
definido o cuando no se especifique
mientras que era
es un símbolo como de relleno de ese
carácter carolina pero entonces cuál es
la facultada y le quiero preguntar
para una persona que desde la argentina
es reconocida con el género x o con la x
en su dni y luego quiere desplazarse a
un país del mercosur o en un caso tal
vez más difícil a europa a asia como
hace para ser reconocido
internacionalmente ese camino ya está
hecho o allanado
generalmente este camino está allanado
esa era una de las problemáticas para
apartarse de la práctica pero a su vez
con este decreto se convalida que
efectivamente esa opción de la equis sea
una opción posible y ampliando así las
capacidades de respuesta apartándose del
binomio femenino y masculino lo que sí
es cierto que la legislación argentina
manda en argentina y no lo es el resto
de las países del mundo por eso en este
descrito que también es una política
pública se estableció que la persona se
le debe informar debidamente que esta
situación puede ser no no comprendida
por otros países que no todos los países
del mundo
comprenden en la x como una categoría
aceptada y para eso que haga ciertas
verificaciones personales antes de hacer
un viaje para ver cuáles son las
condiciones de permanencia resistencia y
tránsito si tuvieran un documento de
estas características pero es un
documento aseguró que hoy en día pudo
adaptarse a estas especificaciones y
ampliando a esta categoría que si estaba
en este estándar internacional pero
hasta ahora hasta el año pasado no se
había contemplado hasta ahora esta
decisión está anclada en nuestra
legislación sobre identidad de género
como bien ustedes repasaron y hasta
ahora siempre los cambios serán mirando
desde género femenino al masculino y del
masculino al femenino sin otra opción
claro y didáctica nos hemos revisado
para ahora recordar un poco su idea son
poco más de seis meses los que llevan la
implementación de esta nueva figura de
la x en el dni de argentina y pues de
ahí la importancia que radica como usted
lo dice en otros países que pueden no
reconocer esa equis y también un paso
grande para la región ya dentro del país
dentro de la argentina como tal han
tenido otras dificultades por ejemplo a
la hora de verificar paternidades o de
solicitar paternidad eso maternidades
hay dificultad en el ejercicio de esta
identidad no definida o del género no
binario
por ahora no no tenemos conocimiento de
esos problemas y hay todavía ajustes que
hay que hacer a la implementación de la
identidad de género que ya lleva a 10
años de implementación próximamente se
cumplen 10 años y siempre hay ajustes de
mejores prácticas que se pueden
garantizar para la ciudadanía y sobre
todo como corolario de las relaciones
familiares las rectificaciones de
partidas de los hijos de las personas
que hicieron una rectificación por su
identidad de género autopercibida
todavía son cosas que se van ajustando y
que lo que se trata es de que no se
judiciales en que se pueda dar una
respuesta
administrativa pero todavía se van
ajustando pero si hay una amplia
aceptación y se van modificando los
distintos registros como por ejemplo los
registros de previsión social
se están modificando los números que
vienen acompañados del género para
precisamente que esto no sea un problema
hay otros países desde luego en el
continente canadá se había tenido una
buena práctica al respecto que nosotras
las argentinas lo están revisando
carolina habla que tengo que interrumpir
porque me quedan muertas preguntas y ya
se nos acaba el tiempo
rápidamente ya viendo ya vimos digamos
el lado difícil de la implementación
para algunos conservadores una equis no
cambia el tema de la discriminación y no
es representativa yo le quiero preguntar
a usted porque si es ese pequeño cambio
de letra en el dni puede representar un
gran cambio de vida para los ciudadanos
que son diversos o que hacen parte de la
comunidad del gti con más
exactamente porque estaba este cambio
esta opción que se vino a sumar es la
nomenclatura eco x para las personas que
son no binarias y que decidieran
considerar que esa x es indeterminado no
especificado indefinido lo informado en
el texto género
autopercibido o no consignado como
femenino masculino para las pelas y la
aceptan tienen una opción posible que
reconoce su identidad de género
autopercibida y éstos al día de hoy va a
noviembre del 2021 cuando tuvimos acceso
a las últimas cifras vimos que el 12 por
ciento de la población trans que había
hecho sus rectificaciones eran personas
no binarias y que precisamente a
noviembre ya casi 11 mil personas fueron
usuarias de la ley de identidad de
género sin problemas importan hoy en día
un dni un pasaporte válido para la
argentina para la región para el mundo
que las reconocen con una identidad de
género autopercibida distinta
a consignar el momento del nacimiento
consideremos que la población argentina
es una población de el censo de 2010 de
40 millones 120 mil habitantes y que ya
11.000 personas hicieron su
rectificación pues
argentina y otros avances como el
próximo censo va a considerar la
categoría de género autopercibido para
que cada ciudadano ciudadana ciudadano
pueda decir cuál es su género
autopercibido y ahí se puedan desagregar
datos importantes sobre las condiciones
de vida de la población trans el
genérico disidencias y etcétera etcétera
etcétera y mire es que no es poca cosa
decir quién soy yo y cómo me identifico
muchísimas gracias carolina por estar en
ella soy una de las tareas de este
programa es precisamente teclear la
discriminación por razones de género así
que pues desde aquí un agradecimiento a
ustedes y sobre todo un agradecimiento
por ese paso que da argentinas adelante
en la región latinoamericana feliz y de
trabajo contribuyen a visibilizar y al
reconocimiento de las identidades y las
expresiones de género sin discriminación
muchas gracias a ustedes y esa es la
tarea nuestro cede televidentes los
invitamos a seguir en france 24 y nos
vemos próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]